en este vídeo quiero hacer un breve
repaso acerca de las medianas de un
triángulo y luego quiero contarte una
propiedad interesante que cumplen que
será útil después para resolver algunos
problemas entonces déjame empezar
dibujando aquí un triángulo y vamos a
recordar que es una mediana de hecho un
triángulo tiene tres medianas y una
mediana consiste en tomar uno de los
vértices del triángulo y unirlo con el
punto medio del lado opuesto entonces
por ejemplo esta de acá sería una
mediana pensando que este es igual a
este otra mediana sería tomar digamos
este vértice de aquí arriba y unirlo con
el punto medio de aquí abajo de este
lado de acá donde esto mide lo mismo que
esto entonces nos quedaría más o menos
algo así y finalmente la tercera mediana
sería unir este vértice con el tercer
punto medio quedaría más o menos algo
así
y algo padre de las medianas es que las
tres pasan por un mismo punto y ese
punto por el cual pasan se conoce como
el centro hoy desde el triángulo y se
llama centro yo por razones físicas o
sea se llama centro d porque si este
triángulo fuera un triángulo real un
digamos hecho de metal y el metal
estuviera distribuido uniformemente
entonces este punto sería el centro de
masa del triángulo vale bueno esta es
una cosa interesante y otra cosa
interesante es que si lanzáramos este
triángulo no se déjame dibujarlo por acá
antes de lanzarlo entonces si lo
lanzamos y lo lanzaremos de tal forma
que empezará a girar entonces el
triángulo justo giraría alrededor del
centro y bueno estas son cosas
interesantes pero la idea de este vídeo
no es convertirnos en ninjas y empezar a
aventar triángulos de metal más bien lo
que te quiero contar es una propiedad
interesante que cumplen las medianas de
un triángulo y es la siguiente
resulta que el centro y de divide a las
medianas a cada una de ellas en razón
uno a dos donde uno es el lado que está
más cercano al punto medio es decir si
esta longitud me diera a entonces ésta
de acá me diría 2a
otra forma de decirlo es que el centro
hoy de esta a dos tercios de distancia
del vértice con respecto al punto medio
entonces hay que avanzar dos tercios de
la mediana para llegar aquí bueno está
aquí es una propiedad padrísima está
bien suave pero pues no vamos a
aceptarlas y ciegamente para no tener
que hacer un acto de fe vamos a
demostrar la vale y para demostrar la
voy a hacer un dibujo en tres
dimensiones la cosa de pasar figuras de
n dimensiones a n son dimensiones es que
ayuda un poco a simplificar las cuentas
entonces déjame pintar por aquí unos
unos ejes en tres dimensiones ahí
tenemos el eje z por acá vamos a poner
el eje x y por acá el eje y vale el eje
entonces aquí tenemos el eje x el eje y
ese problema que hicimos de un tetraedro
hubiera salido más fácil en cuatro
dimensiones pero ya es un poco más
difícil de visualizar pero bueno
entonces tenemos el eje x el jee y el
zeta y vamos a tomar los tres vértices
tres vértices de un triángulo digamos
este de acá
este de acá esté acá y este de acá vale
y no sé vamos a pensar déjame déjame
primero trazar los lados para crear el
triángulo va a ser esto de aquí este de
aquí un poco más bonito este de acá y
este de acá y vamos a pensar que las
coordenadas son son esto es lo bueno de
estar en 3-d que hay muchos ceros son a
00.00 que aquí es 100 v0 porque estamos
en el eje y la segunda coordenada es la
única que es distinta de cero y
finalmente aquí va a ser 0 0 c muy bien
entonces ya tenemos nuestro triángulo
dibujado es un triángulo arbitral bueno
una cosa que no voy a demostrar pero que
voy a usar es que el centro está justo
en el promedio de estos tres puntos es
decir que las coordenadas del centro y
de las coordenadas del centro y de
digamos que ésta lo voy a pintar con
amarillo para que se vea que está aquí
las coordenadas justo son promediar las
coordenadas d
tres puntos o sea sería a cero cero a
tercios coma
0 0 b es b b tercios son tercios porque
son tres coordenadas estamos promediando
las y finalmente se de tercios 600 s
dividido entre tres tercios entonces
esta es una propiedad que no voy a
aprobar pero tú puedes probar la por tu
cuenta puedes encontrar la ecuación de
la mediana que sería unir este punto con
el punto medio de acá que ahorita vamos
a pintar luego trazar otra mediana y ver
dónde se intersectan pero justo queda
que es este punto de aquí vale bueno
entonces vamos a comparar las distancias
que se forman la distancia de digamos
este vértice de acá a este punto al
centro hoy d
con con la distancia del centro de al
punto medio punto vale entonces esto de
aquí es la mediana lo que yo digo es que
la distancia naranja es el doble de la
amarilla entonces vamos a ver qué día de
veras eso es cierto pero para eso vamos
a necesitar el punto medio de este lado
y el punto medio otra vez es promediar
estos dos entonces sería a cero entre
dos está medios luego b cero entre dos
medios y luego 00 entre dos o sea cero
vale bueno entonces vamos a calcular la
distancia a naranja para calcular la
distancia naranja tenemos que sacar una
raíz cuadrada raíz cuadrada tenemos que
restar las coordenadas elevarlas al
cuadrado y sumarlas entonces sería a
tercios menos 0 al cuadrado sería a
tercios al cuadrado o sea sería a
cuadrada sobre 9 ya eso tenemos que
sumarle b tercios menos 0 al cuadrado
sería b cuadrada sobre 9 y finalmente
finalmente tenemos que sumar c tercios
menos c al cuadrado c tercios menos c es
menos dos tercios menos dos tercios al
cuadrado
es cuatro novenos pero tenemos hay una c
entonces es cuatro novenos cuatro
novenos cuatro novenos de c cuadrada y
de hecho esto lo podemos simplificar un
poquito como la raíz cuadrada de a
cuadrada más be cuadrada más cuatro c
cuadrada dividido entre entre la raíz de
nueve o sea entre tres muy bien entonces
esa de ahí es la distancia naranja esto
de aquí mi de raíz de la cuadra damas b
cuadrada más 4 c cuadrada entre text va
ahora vamos con la distancia amarilla
con esta de acá y es la misma idea
tenemos que restar las coordenadas y
luego tenemos que elevar al cuadrado
sumar todo eso y sacar a raíz bueno
entonces vamos a hacer a medios menos a
tercios a medios es tres textos de a y a
tercios es dos sextos de a entonces nos
queda un sexto de a si este menos éste
es un sexto día y ese un sexto de a
tenemos que elevarlo al cuadrado
entonces nos quedaría a cuadrada al
cuadrado entre
36 vale de manera similar de manera
similar
- b tercios de sextos vez éstos al
cuadrado es p cuadrada entre 36 y
finalmente tenemos que hacer 0 - cd
tercios que sería simplemente pues menos
de tercios eso al cuadrado es cuadrada
entre 9 pero de una vez le voy a poner
denominador común se cuadrado entre 9 se
cuadra de entre 9 es lo mismo que cuatro
se cuadrada entre 36 entonces nos quedan
4 se cuadrada entre 36 y de aquí podemos
simplificar nos quedaría la raíz
cuadrada de a cuadrada a cuadrada más b
cuadrada más 4 cuadrada con otros de
cuadradas dividido entre la raíz de 36
que es 6 muy bien ya tenemos la
distancia naranja ya tenemos la
distancia amarilla y observa que la
distancia naranja al dividirla entre 2
nos queda la distancia amarilla vale
entonces la distancia naranja es el
doble de la distancia amarilla la
distancia naranja es el doble de la
vista
amarilla y entonces probamos esta
propiedad que te dije aquí arriba vale
osea que si tomamos el centro y de
entonces está a dos tercios de la
distancia de el vértice hacia el punto
medio o bien que el centro y de divide
en razón uno a dos
la mediana del triángulo y todo lo
hicimos con un triángulo general no
supusimos nada acerca del triángulo
bueno esta propiedad es muy interesante
está bien padre y es importante que la
recuerdes porque después la vamos a
utilizar en algunos otros problemas